HYUNYOUNG SONG: OK,
is this mic on?
OK, mic is alive.
Hello, everybody.
Did everybody find some
place to sit?
OK, I will start now.
Hello, everybody.
Welcome to Void Your Warranty,
Hacking Your Glass session.
My name is Hyunyoung Song.
I also go by HY.
PIERRE-YVES LALIGAND: And I'm
Pierre-Yves Laligand.
I go by PY.
HYUNYOUNG SONG: And
we're Google[x]
software engineers.
So before I go and dive right
into the talk, I'd like to do
a short recap of what has
already been covered at
probably the two previous Glass
rec sessions, Developers
for Glass and Mirror API.
So the name of our Glass
system's main interface is
called the Timeline.
It is basically a strip of cards
laid out horizontally.
And when the screen is woken up,
the first screen that you
see is the clock screen.
And to its right, you have past
event Timeline item cards
that are generated when you
take a photo, or record a
video, or even receive
an email.
And to its left are your future
event cards, such as
Now card and navigation
directions.
If you are a third party
service, the way you can
insert static Timeline item
cards into our main interface
is using Mirror API, which
is a cloud API.
And by design, this was designed
to be simple and easy
to use so that developers don't
have to worry about
managing system resources
such as power lock--
wake lock, and camera,
and so forth.
For those tasks, PY and myself
and many engineers in the
Glass team are actively
working on
designing Glass SDK.
[APPLAUSE]
HYUNYOUNG SONG: And at the time
of the Explorer edition
launch, we thought that we want
to get early input as
much as possible.
And so for every one of you to
actually explore our platform,
we inserted several tools, such
as ADP and Fastboot OEM
Unlock so that you can explore
our Glass platform so we can
get our early feedback
on what you'd like to
see in Glass SDK.
And while we were doing that,
we also decided to hold this
session so that we can guide
you step by step what you'd
have to do to use these tools.
So you all probably
know that Glass is
built on top of Android.
And so here, I'd like to see
a quick show of hands.
How many of you have developed
Android applications?
This is very good.
And OK, so then, how many of
you have downloaded Android
open source projects and changed
them, modified it, and
built it, and pushed it to
some mobile platform?
So I like also this show
of hands, too.
So since most of you already
know about Android platform
and how to build applications,
we will not cover how you can
program and develop
Glass applications
today in this session.
What we will be covering are
basically two things.
The first thing, how you can
modify your existing Android
applications so that you can
run it on Glass platform to
try it out.
And while you're doing that, if
you come to a show stopper
where you can't do certain
things because you don't have
root access, the second part of
this talk, we're going to
tell you the commands that you
have to execute in order to
root your Glass device.
[APPLAUSE]
HYUNYOUNG SONG: So let's first
talk about how you can run
your Android applications
on Glass without
voiding your warranty.
So Android Debug Bridge is
something that you want to
enable and use.
On the laptop, the client side,
you'd want to download
the latest Android SDK.
And under Platform Tools
directory, there will be a
tool, ADB, that you can use to
talk to your Glass device when
it's connected to your USB.
And on Glass device, there's
settings device info cards
that PY will show you later on
in this demo, how you can
toggle the debug settings.
And here's some of the things
that you probably want to
consider when you're modifying
your Android applications to
run on Glass platform.
Currently, Explorer edition is
built on top of Android ICS
MR1 version 4.0.4
API level 15.
So what this means is that in
your Android manifest file,
you want to target the
API level to be 15.
But this does not mean that at
the time of our consumer
launch this is the operating
system that it
will be based on.
So keep that in mind.
Now, in terms of hardware, most
of the communication and
motion sensors are available
through Android standard APIs.
But what is different is
the touch handling.
Instead of having a touch
screen, Glass has a touch pad
on the side.
And so if your input handling
depends on any screen
coordinates, then it
will not work.
So you'd want to change that
to something that can take
focus and something that can
use more or less D-pad like
operations.
In terms of the display, as
opposed to having LCD that is
opaque, Glass system has a
display that is 25 inches,
eight foot away display that is
translucent or transparent.
The key word here is
"transparent."
You want the best contrast
as possible.
And in order to have this
effect, you want to change
your background to be black and
have white text or light
text to have the
best contrast.
And this will probably save your
battery life a lot, too.
So now, PY's going to do
a demo of Launcher, and
settings, and a Notepad app that
we downloaded from these
open sources.
PIERRE-YVES LALIGAND:
All right.
Thank you very much, HY.
So first, before I get into the
demo, I'd like to briefly
talk about our set-up.
So the window that you can see
at the bottom of my screen is
a tool called ScreenCast,
which we
developed on the team.
It will allow me to share
with you what's
showing up on my device.
In addition, the device that
I'm currently wearing is,
software wise, really similar to
the ones that I see on some
heads in attendance.
It's just that I have an older
hardware revision.
Lucky you!
Another thing that I'd
like to point out.
If you have Bluetooth devices,
we'd really appreciate it if
you could turn them
off at this point.
That would make this
demo much easier.
Thank you.
All right, so let's get
on with the demo.
So the first part I want to show
you is pretty much as a
very strict prerequisite for
everything you're going to do
after that is to enable ADB.
So when I wake the device up
and you land on the clock
guard, all you have to do is
swipe all the way back until
you reach the settings card.
Once you're in the settings
bundle, look for
the device info card.
Tap to reach Options.
And then, the second one
is the ADB toggle.
So right now, as you can see, I
already have ADB on because
Under the Hood, that's what's
ScreenCast needs in order to
be able to pull some frame off
of the device and show them to
you on my laptop.
So right now, we have
ADB enabled.
And there are a lot of
things we can do.
And the first thing we're
going to do is actually
install some apps.
So what HY and I have done is
actually downloaded the source
code for a couple of apps.
So Launcher and Settings from
the Android open source
project, pretty much
just compiled those
into regular APKs.
And now, I'm in the process of
installing them on my device.
So we didn't really have to
modify the sources with one
little exception.
In the settings applications
manifest file, there's a line
that needs to be changed.
But I'm not going to
tell you any more.
I'll leave that as a homework
for you later.
All right, so now my
apps are installed.
I'm going to just turn
the device back on.
And as you can see, now,
something that should look
very familiar to some of you.
And I have the option
to choose several
different home apps.
So for the purpose of this demo,
I'm just going to use
the Android Launcher.
And here you go.
If you have--
[APPLAUSE]
PIERRE-YVES LALIGAND:
Thank you.
So if you've ever played with an
Android device before, this
should look very familiar.
So now, I can go into
the App section.
And sure enough, here are
setting that I just installed.
So usually, when I do this demo,
the first thing I do--
and this is a great example--
I go directly to the
Display section.
Then, I reach for the
Sleep property.
And I bump it all the way up
because I'm tired of seeing my
screen do time out on me.
All right.
Let's go.
Here it is.
So you probably noticed that
in order to get around the
apps, I'm using the touch pad
that is mounted on the right
side of my frame.
So this is possible because of
some slight modifications we
made to the Android platform.
So by default, if touch pad
input events go unhandled,
they get automatically
transformed
into navigation events.
So for example, forward and
backward swipes or horizontal
slides get turned into
focus motion events.
Taps are used to select.
And swipes down simply
have the back action.
So this is pretty powerful.
And if you install any apps on
a Glass device, it will allow
you to navigate around
the apps and reach
a lot of its features.
Unfortunately, if your app
wasn't really designed with
Glass in mind, then you're going
to find out that, for
example, if you have a lot
of focusable widget or if
basically your app was designed
for a touch screen,
this just won't cut it.
Thankfully, this is
an Android device.
And like most Android devices,
this guy has a Bluetooth chip.
And it supports the HID profile,
which allows it to
pair with a lot of
input devices.
So for this demo, I picked
this little keyboard.
It's a very simple Bluetooth
keyboard.
You can buy it on the shelf,
or you can buy it online.
So I really like this one
because it already has some
hard keys for us, some Android
system function IDs,
like Home and Back.
So that comes in very handy.
So all right, that's the moment
where I'm supposed to
cross my fingers and try
to pair it with Glass.
All right, luckily we have
the Settings app.
I go to the Bluetooth section.
And if I don't forget to turn
it on, maybe it's going to
show up alongside the
1,500 devices
there are in this room.
All right, hey, I've
got your name.
We're going to filter when you
exit who ruined my demo.
All right, so let's
try this again.
I'm going to try to
turn it back on.
And let me know if you spot
a keyboard in here.
Yup, aha!
Yes!
Oh.
All right, one more time.
Yeah, this one, too.
All right, it's [INAUDIBLE].
HYUNYOUNG SONG: Let's keep
our fingers crossed.
PIERRE-YVES LALIGAND: Come on!
Oh,
HYUNYOUNG SONG: Okay.
PIERRE-YVES LALIGAND: We'll
try this again.
We have time.
Bluetooth again, turn it on.
It's discoverable.
It was there.
HYUNYOUNG SONG: Yay!
PIERRE-YVES LALIGAND: Yes.
OK, so now I'm there.
Now, I have to type this little
code, 4133, Enter.
And despite what this guy is
saying, I can tell you that
I'm already paired.
All right, get out of there.
So now, I can use the D-pad
on the device to just
get around the app.
And also, this guy
has a mouse pad.
So I can have a mouse pointer,
which is super handy for touch
screen apps.
So this is actually very useful
if you intend to port
an existing app onto Glass.
And the reason for that is
that it will allow you to
start with a fully functional
app, and then gradually adjust
it to work great with the form
factor, with the display
technology, with the input
modalities, and whatnot.
The alternative, if you don't
do that, is to pretty much
start from scratch.
And you're going to have to pay
a huge upfront cost to get
to a version that is kind of,
sort of working, which is,
believe me, time consuming
and very annoying.
All right, to demonstrate this a
little further, I'm going to
go ahead and install the third
app, which is the Notepad app.
All right, let's do this.
So just like the previous two
apps, you can find it in the
Android open source project, or
if you have already an SDK
installation on your computer,
you can probably find it
somewhere in the samples
directory.
So I'm just going to go there.
It's in the Apps section
that I have Notes.
And sure enough, I can
operate it as if it
was on a touch screen.
Can someone control my screen
time out being [INAUDIBLE].
OK, so I create a new note.
And I type, "hello
io." I can save.
So basically, I can use all the
functionalities of the app.
And then, from that point on,
I'm going to gradually roll
out improvement and make
it better on Glass.
So to summarize what we've seen,
one, you can easily turn
on ADB on Glass.
Two, you can use it
to install apps.
And three, Bluetooth devices are
quite handy if you want to
tinker with these apps.
Back to you, HY.
HYUNYOUNG SONG: Thank you, PY.
[APPLAUSE]
HYUNYOUNG SONG: So now this
time, I am going to share with
you a video that we received
from one of our Explorers,
High Fidelity, Inc. They're one
of our Glass Explorers.
And what they did is they
created an Avatar app using
the motion sensors
and microphone
of the Glass platform.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Hey, this is Ryan from
High Fidelity.
We're obsessed here with low
latency avatar and avatar
communication.
And we've been taking advantage
of all this cool
hardware that's got the
sensors in it, Glass
being one of those.
And you can see that we've built
a simple APK here that
transmits its sensor data and
Glass's sensor data over UDP
need to our client and
moves the avatar's
head as I move around.
We've got it locked in
at about 50 hertz.
Pretty cool stuff.
[APPLAUSE]
HYUNYOUNG SONG: So
all that was fun.
But there are still things that
you cannot do by just
enabling ADB.
You cannot access user data
directory, which has all the
cool key value pairs and the SQL
Lite 3 database that you
want to tinker with.
I see some nods there.
And just in case you want to
grab, get permissions for
certain platform resources that
are already held by Glass
stack applications, then you'd
probably want to delete some
of the Glass APKs, which you
will not be able to do if
you're not rid of your device.
So that's something
you cannot do.
And last but not least, you
cannot replace the operating
system of the Glass device.
Similar to how developers
replace Android operating
system with [? Cyanogen ?]
mod.
So now, I'll go onto the second
part of this talk.
I will go through how you can
gain that root access.
So there are five commands that
you have to execute to
gain root access on
off-the-shelf Glass device.
First command reboots
into the bootloader.
That implements Fastboot
protocol on top of a USB
device driver.
Now, in order for your laptop
to talk with your Glass in
this bootloader state, you'd
want to use the Fastboot tool
that you downloaded in a
similar way that you
downloaded ADB tool.
Now, one thing to note, though,
is I actually tried on
multiple platforms.
And only the Fastboo tool from
Linux platform works.
And Mac version, unfortunately,
does not work.
So keep that in mind.
AUDIENCE: I put that together.
HYUNYOUNG SONG: Well, I'm glad
you have the answer.
He's the person that you
want to talk to if
you want to do that.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
HYUNYOUNG SONG: Secondly, you'd
want to execute Fastboot
OEM Unlock, which removes--
basically, it gives you access
to override any system
partitions.
But what this does is it
removes any security
precautions.
And because we didn't want
anybody to actually grab your
device and execute this command
to access any of your
important user data, as a
byproduct of this command,
it'll erase all your user data
and all your cache and make it
the state as when you execute
factory reset, basically.
But this doesn't actually
give you root access.
The third command, which
overrides a boot partition
with boot image that you can
download from this site,
probably sometime before the
end of I/O, developer under
glass under downloads, this will
enable you to actually
gain root access.
What boot image does is it
contains RAM disk that defines
a lot of system properties,
including which shell and
which services gain access to
which partitions and so forth.
And finally, you would want to
get out of this bootloader.
And then, in the regular mode,
you'd want to execute ADB
root, which will finally
grant you root access.
Now, I'm going to show you a
video of how this was all
executed on PY's laptop.
So first, you'd want to execute
ADB devices to verify
that your Glass device
is connected.
And by default, you don't
have access to my
favorite data partition.
And so you try to gain by
adb root, but it fails.
So you execute the first
command, adb
reboot-bootloader.
And then, there's a fast
forward because
this takes some time.
And now, I verify that it is
in bootloader state by
Fastboot devices.
And then, execute Fastboot
OEM unlock.
But the first one doesn't do
anything but prints out
warning messages.
Don't do this!
And then, if you're really
sure, execute that second
command, which will erase
the user data.
It takes about five minutes
because it's about 13 gigs of
data that it erases as
of this process.
And then, execute that
overriding command to swap out
and override boot partition.
And then, reboot into
normal state.
Now, still, I don't have access
to that data partition
because I didn't execute
the last command.
And so, I execute it.
And now, voila, yes.
[APPLAUSE]
HYUNYOUNG SONG: You have access
to the data partition.
So when I was asked to do this
demo, or do this talk, I
wanted to show you an awesome
demo what you can do on a
Glass device.
And it had to be all in house--
it cannot be in-house
Google technology.
So I asked around and ask our
good friend, Greg, who's a
Glass engineer who's been in the
team for longer than us.
He actually programs on his
Glass device using Emacs that
is running on Ubuntu.
So I asked him, OK, Greg, what
did you do to have Ubuntu
running there?
And he's like, oh,
it's very easy.
Just download these two apps
from the Play Store.
The first one will run
the terminal for you.
And then, the second one, it
downloads the scripts so that
it downloads the modified
Ubuntu image and all the
BusyBox and [? ShareRoot ?]
and all these command line
tools that you'll need in
order to set up an Ubuntu
environment.
So we did that.
And now, PY's actually going to
show you a demo of a device
that is running Ubuntu
on top of Glass.
PIERRE-YVES LALIGAND: All
right, thanks, HY.
So you may have seen
that I switched
devices between the demo.
So those are pretty
much identical.
The only difference is that this
one went through all the
steps that you just
saw in the video.
And also, as you can see, we've
installed the two apps
that HY just mentioned.
So I'm going to go ahead
and just enter
the terminal emulator.
And the first thing I want to do
is switch to the Superuser.
All right.
And despite that error message,
I can tell you I have
superpowers right now.
So I'm then going to go to the
directory where the images
were installed, that's
this one.
Let's see if we have
everything there.
Yep, we have the images.
And we even have this little
strip that actually does all
the hard work of starting
everything.
Oops, let me try that again.
Here it is.
Basically, what it does, it
mounts the images and just
initializes the operating
system.
And that's it.
So let's try to run it now.
[INAUDIBLE].
Here we go.
Oh, there's stuff happening.
That's usually good, or not.
So let's see now what we
think we're doing if I
can find the backslash.
Here we go.
Now, let's check which
version of Linux
we think we're running.
Yup, this is Ubuntu, and it
has an SSH, I think a VNC
server, and a whole lot of
features that you can then use
on Glass, including Emacs.
Back to you, HY.
[APPLAUSE]
HYUNYOUNG SONG: So the takeaway
message from this
talk is that during this talk,
I introduced to you two modes
where you can explore your Glass
platform, the debug mode
and root mode.
Now, I want to make some
disclaimers here
on each one of these.
So the way that you push Android
APKs on your Glass
device and use it, this is
not really Glass team's
recommended way of creating
a Glass experience.
It's more for you to actually
like play around and go nuts
with whatever you want to do.
That's why we actually did this
demo and showed you all
these methods.
And in terms of gaining that
root access, even though there
are recovery methods, there is
a chance that depending on
what you do, your device may get
stuck in a state where it
will be difficult to recover, in
which case Google will not
be supporting.
So keep that in mind.
And when you do root your
device, you have to be really
sure that you want to do it.
But putting these disclaimers
aside, play with the platform
and share with us and share
with the world the awesome
work that you can do on Glass.
And when you do, these are some
of the communities and
websites that you can ask
questions, get technical tips.
And often, actually, PY and
myself go here, go to these
sites, and see what people are
doing, and talk about it.
And we're excited that you
guys are doing this.
And for people who actually have
a Glass device or just
picked it up, there's also
Explorer community that you
can join, where you can also get
more information on Mirror
API, Hacking Glass, and
all general questions.
So do visit these websites.
And on that note, thank
you so much.
[APPLAUSE]
HYUNYOUNG SONG: And we'll
take questions.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I have
a question.
Are you going to release a
factory image that we can
flash Glass back to its original
configuration?
PIERRE-YVES LALIGAND: Yes.
HYUNYOUNG SONG: Huh?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
PIERRE-YVES LALIGAND:
It's there.
HYUNYOUNG SONG: Well,
it's public now.
PIERRE-YVES LALIGAND: So to
answer your question, yes,
we're going to make the factory
images available for
pretty much any version that
we're going to publish.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
PIERRE-YVES LALIGAND:
Yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'm Cedric.
I'm a robotic engineering
student.
So I want to know if it's
possible to connect Glass to
older hardware, like Arduino and
everything related to it.
PIERRE-YVES LALIGAND: That's
a good question.
Actually, so as you probably
imagine, the Glass device has
a micro USB port, and you
can connect stuff to it.
I personally haven't tried and
see what you can do with it.
But I invite you to give it a
shot if you can, and then let
us know how it goes.
And then, from there, we can
take your feedback back to the
team and see how we can
make it better for
this kind of hacking.
AUDIENCE: OK, thank you.
PIERRE-YVES LALIGAND: Sure.
HYUNYOUNG SONG: Let's
take over there.
AUDIENCE: Hello, hello.
So one of the issues with
having ADB debug mode
available from the settings menu
is that it's very easy to
turn that feature on without--
because there's no kind
of PIN code lock.
I mean, if I were to, for
instance, have access to your
Glass for even, like, 30
seconds, I can very easily get
ADB debug mode on.
At what point, I can now install
services on your
device, even without having
to get root access.
And then, of course, I can
oftentimes use an exploit now
in order to escalate
to root access.
I was wondering if the Glass
team had any plans on being
able to put some kind of
security on the device when
it's just sitting?
PIERRE-YVES LALIGAND: Yeah,
that's definitely an issue
that we have in mind.
And we have people working
on it currently.
So stay tuned.
HYUNYOUNG SONG: So notice,
this is actually Explorer
edition that you guys
are trying out.
On the consumer launch version,
there will be more
security precaution settings
that you'll be able to make
sure that they're safe.
AUDIENCE: As somebody who has
the Explorer edition, and
purposely not wearing it here
at I/O today because I'd be
concerned that somebody, for
instance, would be able to get
into it, it just is concerning
even before release right now.
PIERRE-YVES LALIGAND: I think
you can trust these people.
They're cool.
Sir?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
My name is Mark.
I would like to know, because
you just flashed a new boot
image for a rooted mode, is
there a boot image available
to go back to the [? OTA ?]
updates mode?
PIERRE-YVES LALIGAND: So I think
that goes back to the
question the other
gentleman had.
We're going to make all the
factory images available.
And that will include all the
images you need to do that.
AUDIENCE: OK, that's great.
PIERRE-YVES LALIGAND:
Yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: Hi, my
name is Ethan.
I have to say I'm really excited
about the debug mode
capabilities, and thank
you guys for bringing
it to all of us.
Two questions come to mind.
One is, is it possible to get to
the same voice recognition
that you use in the core app?
Number one.
And number two, the on-head
detection, I don't know what
the sensor is, can we get
access to that, as
well, on our own?
PIERRE-YVES LALIGAND: So for the
first part of the question
about voice recognition, I
think that's definitely
something that we're thinking
about integrating and allowing
you to access.
I'm not 100% sure of
what the state is.
But you might want to try to
use the standard recognizer
Intents that are available on
Android and see what it does.
But I think we're working
on trying to bring
that level of support.
As for on-head detection, I
don't think there's anything
available at this point.
But do you have any other
application in mind for that?
AUDIENCE: I'm sure I could
think of something.
PIERRE-YVES LALIGAND: Great!
Just let us know.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
PIERRE-YVES LALIGAND:
Yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
My name's Dante.
Looking around the room, there
are a lot of people with
Glass, but most people
still don't have it.
Is there any time frame we could
expect from Google, like
a bigger roll out to more
developers, more Explorers?
PIERRE-YVES LALIGAND: So
currently, the Explorer
program is closed.
We might reopen it for
applications at some point.
I think we've already announced
that we're trying to
shoot for having a consumer
release by
the end of the year.
We're working really hard for
that when we're not giving
talks at I/O. So stay
tuned, again.
There's no more information
that I can
give you at this point.
But we're trying to.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
PIERRE-YVES LALIGAND:
Yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: So given that you're
making an official native dev
kit available, how do you see
those types of apps being
delivered to consumer devices?
Is there going to be
a store or some
kind of delivery platform?
PIERRE-YVES LALIGAND: This
delivery is a big part of our
work, right?
We can't just provide an SDK and
hope that people will find
a way to install apps.
So as HY mentioned, this is
something we're pretty
actively working
on these days.
Again, unfortunately,
I have nothing
official to announce here.
But rest assured, there's going
to be a good delivery
mechanism for those, just as
you would expect from a
regular Android device.
HYUNYOUNG SONG: But for the
Glass wearers, you can already
go to my Glass website
[INAUDIBLE]
and install some of the
[INAUDIBLE] and Path and some
of those third party apps.
So you can install those already
and try them out.
And if we figured that that is
where we should also keep the
apps, that could be one place.
There's actually--
this is an open question,
really.
PIERRE-YVES LALIGAND: Sir?
AUDIENCE: I'm Luca.
Two questions.
One, once it's rooted, can I
get access to the camera
stream, and just standard
Android, or is there something
funky with that?
HYUNYOUNG SONG: [SHAKES HEAD]
PIERRE-YVES LALIGAND: Can
I get this mic back?
HYUNYOUNG SONG: Or I can talk.
PIERRE-YVES LALIGAND:
So actually, I'm
going to speak louder.
So actually, you don't even
need to root for that.
You can just use the standard
camera APIs or
even the camera Intents.
And you're going to get
access to the camera.
It's a standard Android
device.
AUDIENCE: Oh, okay.
And what about NDK support?
That's the second question.
PIERRE-YVES LALIGAND: Native.
As part of the SDK effort, we're
also looking at NDK.
Again, nothing to
announce here.
But I think that would be
pretty cool to have
something--
AUDIENCE: But if I root
it, I can get full NDK
access, then, right?
PIERRE-YVES LALIGAND: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Okay, cool, thanks.
AUDIENCE: Somewhat related
to that question.
Do we have access to-- without
rooting, do we have access to
all of the hardware, including
that eye-tracking whatever
thing on the inside?
PIERRE-YVES LALIGAND: That's
the same thing that the
gentleman before.
I don't think there's
anything yet.
You can try.
AUDIENCE: Okay.
So the demo with the head moving
around, the video that
you played, that did not require
rooting, correct?
PIERRE-YVES LALIGAND: No, no,
I think they were just using
the accelometer, magnetometer,
and gyroscope, and that's it.
AUDIENCE: Okay.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
My name is [? Walam ?].
I know we don't need an Android
physical device to
develop for Android because
we have the emulator.
Is there a similar plan to
ship something like an
emulator for the Glass so that
the ones who don't have it yet
explore it?
PIERRE-YVES LALIGAND: That's
a good question, actually
something that we talked about
in our design team.
I think that's something that
we can definitely do.
And I hope that we can provide
something along those lines.
But really, I think in order to
correctly develop an app, I
think you really need
at least one device.
Because you need to
see how it feels.
It's really, really different in
terms of experience from a
phone or a tablet.
But as part of the SDK for it,
of course we're thinking about
not only APIs, but also tools
that we can provide you with
so that you can do your job
and build awesome apps.
AUDIENCE: Hey.
Any plans to expose the Labs
features to users?
PIERRE-YVES LALIGAND: What?
Do what?
AUDIENCE: The Labs features
in the framework?
HYUNYOUNG SONG: What is Labs?
I don't know what Labs are.
PIERRE-YVES LALIGAND: Which--?
AUDIENCE: There's Lab features
in the Glass software which,
like, turn on the browser, turn
on [? Win ?] support,
turn on voice, all throughout
the device.
PIERRE-YVES LALIGAND: This
is not something I
think we plan to expose.
This is something just internal
at this point.
AUDIENCE: Okay, thanks.
PIERRE-YVES LALIGAND: I think
we're going to take the last
question because we're running
out of time, so,
you're the lucky one.
AUDIENCE: My name is
Arthur Benhoff.
I've been building a few apps
using the Mirror API.
I'm really excited about this.
I want to know if there's a way
to launch an APK in normal
mode from the Timeline.
And if so, can I know what
the user's identity is?
PIERRE-YVES LALIGAND: So what do
you mean by "normal mode?"
AUDIENCE: So I know I can
install an APK and
launch it using ADB.
But how do I start an
application using--?
PIERRE-YVES LALIGAND: That's
a good question.
So again, as part of the SDK
effort, we're really looking
at the entry points into the
existing Glass experience.
I think we have a couple
of ideas at this point.
If you have some more, please
let us because we'd be really
interested.
But yeah, we're going to have
something along this line.
AUDIENCE: What about
the credentials?
HYUNYOUNG SONG: Just
one more, Alan.
AUDIENCE: Alan Furst, I know
I'm not going to make it--
PIERRE-YVES LALIGAND: So I think
we're running out of
time right now.
But we're going to be hanging
out outside of the room if you
have more questions.
So thanks again for coming up.
HYUNYOUNG SONG: So a
personal question.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]